hey what's up guys welcome to another hd
tutorial and in this video i'll be
showing you as you can see by the title
how to make a relatively basic um a
relatively basic channel icon using [ __ ]
now you can see by the sidebars i
already have [ __ ] open for you and what
i'm going to do is uh first of all we're
going to create a square icon
so we're going to go to file and new and
we're going to create a new 200 by 200
sorry 200 project now depending on how
high the resolution or high uh high the
um
i'm sorry depending on how high the
resolution or uh density you want it to
be you can make it a larger size maybe
400 by 400 it'll be a little crisper but
it'll also be a larger file size so just
hit ok and here we have our little
square going on here we're going to do
is press this tool over here this is the
blend tool and we're going to choose a
background and a foreground color we're
just going to blend black and red for
this one so just uh drag it to the spot
where you want and hit ok
and then we're just going to kind of
drag
and it'll change the way you may or may
not like it but that's basically you can
choose how long ingredient takes
and that's basically the background of
our icon here the next thing that a lot
of people want to do is add text to it
so what you're going to do is go to the
layer button and select new layer and
it's going to be the same size we can
name it uh text one
and hit ok
and this is going to be just any text we
want so make sure this layer is selected
and click on it
and just hit the a button
and drag yourself a little text box once
you've texted once you've uh created a
text box what do you want it to be well
i have all my channel logos i have about
four of them they're all mkb which is my
initials in all capital letters
you can change a lot of things about
this i'm going to close this but while
this layer is still selected go ahead
and uh increase the size of it okay
uh you can change the font i'll change
this to
uh one of the fonts that i got from
font's website and by the way if you
want to learn how to get free fonts
downloaded on your computer just check
out my video about dafont so here we go
this is going to be the main text of um
of my channel logo right here and once
we finish that a lot of people this is
basically all that i would do but most
people want to ask how do i add another
layer of text well you can either add a
new text box or add a new layer in
general so i'm just going to add a new
text box down here make it say hd
now this is going to be a complete sorry
a completely different size so i'm just
going to shrink that down to about 100
uh probably a little less there we go
and drag it to the middle
so there we go it says marcus brownlee
or mkbhd
and that's a very very very basic way of
creating a channel logo which is exactly
how i created mine now actually in my
channel logo there are three layers of
text so if i do create another text box
here there's a giant x in the background
as people were asking me how i made that
i have this x layer up here
and i actually made the font over here
quite large so it took up the entire
screen
but then instead of making it overlap
everything i made the opacity extremely
low so just by dragging this up here you
can change
the opacity of it and then obviously i
can drag it around
and that's how i made the giant x in the
background so yeah if you guys like this
tutorial this is just a very basic
tutorial on how to make a channel logo
if you do like this logo and you want to
keep it just go ahead and hit file
and save as
and in order to make this uploadable to
youtube i'm going to make it channel
icon
or channel dot png which will save it as
a dot png file select where you want to
save it and hit save
and just hit the export button so that
it's just one giant uh
logo that hit save it'll finish saving
to exactly where you want it you can
exit out of [ __ ] at this point and now
let's go find that channel logo so we'll
go into my pictures
and
here it is this is the one that we just
made now you can see the size is 400 by
400 so if you do decide to upload this
to youtube it will be
very crisp very clear the one i did
which i'm redoing soon is actually 200
by 200 so i'm planning on making that a
lot clearer
obviously my channel my entire channel
is in hd so i might as well make my logo
hd but that's basically it so
that is how i made my channel icon i
know a few of you guys asked how i made
it so now you know if you don't have
[ __ ] already check out my video on how
to download again or just go to the link
in the description with the [ __ ] uh link
so yeah it is freeware um if you have
any tutorial ideas or requests please
message me and subscribe and i will try
to do a request video for you this one
was a request but unfortunately so many
channels requested i cannot put their
link in the description because there's
probably a few that i would miss
but yeah so um thanks for watching this
tutorial and hopefully you guys will get
the best out of my tutorials by the way
the one about how to make an intro in
sony vegas 8 is coming out this week so
please stay tuned for that so again
thanks for watching subscribe peace